ما يحدث في السودان قد تتطاير شظاياه الى
دول الجوار اذا صعد الطرفان القتال لاسباب
تاريخيه واجتماعيه وثقافيه وبسبب الروابط
القبليه بين الشعبين تعد تشاد من اكثر
الدول المهدده بعدم الاستقرار بسبب ما
يجري في السودان تخشى الحكومه التشاديه من
حصول الجماعات المتمرده في تشاد على دعم
عسكري من السودان اذا انفلت الوضع كما
تخشى من هجره لن تقوى على تحمل تبعاتها في
ليبيا المنقسمه على نفسها يسود تخوف من
تحرك مسلحين في اتجاه اراضيها مع العلم ان
تقارير دوليه تحدثت عن مشاركتهم في القتال
في ليبيا من قبل كما يسود التخوف من فتح
باب الهجره غير النظاميه على مصراعيه ما
يمكن ان يعمق الازمه الانسانيه لهؤلاء
المهاجرين في ليبيا اثيوبيا التي خرجت
للتو من حرب داخليه في اقليم تيجراي تخشى
من اي انفلات على حدودها مع السودان خصوصا
ان هناك نزاعا حدوديا بين البلدين كما
تخشى من تدفق كبير المهاجرين مع العلم ان
نحو 50 الف اثيوبي هاجروا الى السودان
خلال حرب تيغراي الاخيره اما دوله جنوب
السودان التي استقلت عن السودان في 2011
فتعاني من توتر مستمر منذ ذاك الحين واي
انفلات في السودان سيشكل خطرا كبيرا على
استقرار هذه الدوله الفتيه ونظرا للتوتر
والصراعات هناك هاجر نحو 800 الف شخص من
جنوب السودان الى السودان ويمكن ان تتعمق
معاناتهم الانسانيه اذا زاد الوضع سوءا في
السودان افريقيا الوسطى اتهمت من قبل
السودان بالضلوع في الصراع المسلح الذي
بدا فيها عام 2013 والان تشير تقارير
غربيه الى ان ميليشيا باغنر الروسيه تنشط
على طرفي الحدود وتتحكم في مناجم الذهب
والماس وتتخوف الدول الغربيه من اي يقوي
الوضع في السودان سطوه باغنر في المنطقه
الموقع الجغرافي للسودان يجعل تاثير ما
يجري فيه يتعدى الدول التي لها حدود معه
فكل دول الاقليم تتخوف من خروج الوضع عن
السيطره خصوصا تلك التي تواجه جماعات
المتطرفه مثل الصومال وتنزانيا والتي تعرف
ان عدم الاستقرار تربه خصمه لنمو التطرف
والارهاب تسود كل هذه المخاوف في منطقه
تشهد واحده من اسوا فترات الجفاف ما يهدد
ايضا بتفاقم ازمات سوء التغذيه والمجاعه